ça fait 30 ans kevin délia présente la
météo et du coup j'ai voulu lui poser la
question est ce que l à son échelle elle
observe un changement dans ses cartes
météo et du coup une détérioration du
climat oui ben je le constate dans les
températures surtout là pour vendredi il
est prévu des 40 degrés non seulement
dans le sud ouest mais aussi dans les
régions centrales 40° à nantes prévu
pour vendredi
incroyable on va pulvériser des records
pour un mois de juin d'autant plus que
cette canicule précoce arrive après un
mois de mai qui avait été le plus chaud
et le plus sec jamais enregistré
le réchauffement climatique
malheureusement et là et bien là est-ce
que parmi vous il y aurait un
psychologue pour chiens parce que
regarder ce qu'il fait il a toujours
fonds concombre ou une courgette ou
quelque chose dans la bouche et en fait
il pas cependant bien une demi heure eh
ben il fait le tour de canapé qui
tournent toutes autour du canapé bizarre
ces modèles
les gendarmes un classique ça mange
toujours
côtoyé véhicule monsieur côté mais c'est
beaucoup
voilà là c'est mon coup de coeur la
maman je vous plus ça va ça va tout ça
fait ça fait mecs sympas abordable on
trouvera sur les autres je gardais
surjoue les pièges à moustiques le
moustique atterri sur le sel pensant que
c'est du sucre à soi c'est il va
s'abreuver dans la capsule qui en fait
rempli de rome bourg et le moustique
trébuche sur le bâton et se tape la tête
contre le caillou merci au revoir bon
ob vous voyez ça
le petit jeu blanc dans les toilettes je
remonte
et ben ce n'est pas un mentos ce n'est
pas un mentos j'ai fait rire une fois
quand j'étais petit j'en ai mangé un
c'était comme en
italie
ou sms
vous
[Musique]